we're trying to understand each other
stop bite this here does the talking for
me I have a very same God made you made
me a net water last night an electrical
fire destroyed East End Elementary
School mom where we gonna go to school
now I'm gonna find you someone feel nice
to go now go ahead back kids go on
attempts go
I hope come on we gonna be school
segregation once then fall I'm gonna get
your ass down a City Hall tonight who's
next
they say you represent a great many
people in this town I'm holding you
committee meeting the council will vote
to either adopt or reject school
integration I need two co-chairs human
an add water and that one I'm the
president and clam he's about to hand
you the keys to school integration and
you go lock the door
[Music]
would you look at that crazy white man
folks in this town want blacks are
staying down school I'm here to protect
my family
so all the betters you don't get in my
world and well I'm gonna get it no wait
what are you trying to understand each
other for once and stop talking for me
I mean you ought to know know what same
God made you made me sometimes there are
necessary for the greater good didn't
have to do that
[Music]
as long as the CP Ellis's of the world
keep getting their way ain't nothing
gonna change she looked at me I got some
come on sir why do you expect I'm
talking about
I'm the president of clay I'm supposed
to hate black folks now if I don't
believe that then I got a problem
now what we talking about it and poke
you oh damn well listen up
[Music]
you
[Music]
you